بنيامين نتنياهو يعود على وشك التحالف مع
اليمين المتطرف لتشكيل حكومه ستكون الاكثر
تشددا وعنصريه في تاريخ اسرائيل الاحد هو
موعد تكليفه رسميا من قبل الرئيس يسحق
هيرتزون حصل زعيم
64 نائبا في الكنيست لقياده الحكومه
المقبله يمثلها هؤلاء احزاب الكود وتحالف
الصهيونيه الدينيه وحركتين شاص
اللتين تمثلان التيار الديني الحديدي
28 يوما لعرض حكومته امام الهيئه العامه
للكنيستا والمده قابله للتمديد 14 يوما
بدا ان بعض المصادر الاسرائيليه رشحات ان
تكون قائمه الحكومه جاهزه للعرض خلال
الاسبوع المقبل بالتزامني مع اول جلسه
للكنيسه المنتخب بح
في اي عوده ستكون لرئيس الوزراء المخضرم
الذي حكم اطول فتره في اسرائيل والمتهم في
قضايا فساد لتامين اغلبيه مستقره من شبه
المؤكد ان يتحالف نتنياهو مع حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه الذي يتزعمه ايتامار بن
غفير وغيره من احزاب اقصى اليمين يثير اسم
بنفير القلق لدى الفلسطينيين وحتى حلفاء
اسرائيل وعلى راسهم الولايات المتحده من
غفير ترعرع في صفوف حركه كاخ الارهابيه
قبل ان يغادرها لاحقا ويكتفي بلقب اليمني
المتطرف في تاريخه ادانه عام 2007
بالتحريض العنصري ودعم جماعه تعتبرها
واشنطن وتل ابيب ارهابيه تحدث الرئيس سهل
عنه خلال مشوارته مع قاده الاحزاب التي
فازت في الانتخابات الاخيره كان ذلك في
نهايه الاجتماع معتقدا ان الميكروفون مغلق
لكن الصوت وصل الى خارج القاعه
لديكم شريك يشعر العالم باسره حولنا
بالقلق ايذاءه لقد قلت له هذا ايضا هذا
ليس للنشر حقا لا اريد التسبب في مشاكل
[ضحك]
التي اعقبت هذا الكلام لا تعكس المخاوف
الحقيقيه من حكومه تضم بنصير مجرد احتمال
توليه
مشكله كبيره داخليا وخارجيا اجب السفير
الامريكي في اسرائيل عندما سئل عنه ان
وظيفته كسفير امريكي هي الاستمرار في دفع
الحوار وايضا الاعتراض على الامور التي لا
توافق عليها واشنطن المفارقه المرعبه ان
بن غفير يطالب بوزاره الامن الداخلي
والصنادا للقناه التلفزيونيه الرسميه
يشترط تخصيص موازنات كبيره للوزراء
ويتطلعوا الى تغيير اوامر اطلاق النار
بحيث يمنح عناصر الشرطه حريه اكبر في
اطلاق النار عند الاشتباه في اشخاص ينهون
تنفيذ عمليات
الزواج السياسي المرتقب بين اليمين
واليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل ليس فيه ما
يدعو للاحتفال